hola de nuevo voy a trabajar con el
problema número 12 porque justo ahí fue
donde nos quedamos en el vídeo pasado
así que estamos en la sección número 9 y
el problema número 12 dice lo siguiente
si todos x
esto es menor que yo y esto a su vez es
menor que cero entonces tanto x como ye
son negativos solamente que 2x sería más
negativo si lo queremos ver de alguna
manera 2x es más negativo que james
entonces cuál de los siguientes incisos
es el más grande y me dan 5 incisos los
voy a poner aquí el inciso am es menos 2
x el inciso b es menos 2 x más
- la suma de estos dos el inciso c es 2x
el inciso d es 0 y el inciso en el
inciso que es menos y me preguntan cuál
de estos números es el más grande así
que bueno aquí hay dos formas de
resolver este problema voy a hacer la
primera forma de resolverlo y ahorita te
cuento la segunda entonces primero lo
que quiero hacer aquí es una recta
numérica vamos a hacer mi recta numérica
y vamos a hacerle unas flechas por acá
otra flecha por acá y voy a suponer que
aquí está el cero y aquí está el cero
date cuenta que ya es menor que cero por
lo tanto ya puede estar como por acá
este sería james y date cuenta que 2x es
menor que yo así que voy a suponer que
2x está por acá aquí está 2x
ahora bien la primera forma de resolver
este problema sería tomarnos un caso
particular es decir vamos a suponer que
como es menor que cero vamos a darle el
valor de menos 1 y 2 x como es un número
menor que james vamos a decir que es
menos 2 date cuenta que tú podrás tomar
cualquier caso particular y este que es
mi caso particular cumple lo que está
escrito aquí arriba 2x es decir menos 2
es más pequeño que james es decir menos
1 y esto a su vez es más pequeño que 0
entonces dado esto que tengo aquí en
este caso particular cuanto es menos 2x
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que menos
por lo que vale 2x pero 2 x dijimos que
valía en este caso particular menos 2
así que me quedaría menos por menos 2 y
esto es igual a 2 positivo menos 2 x en
este caso es 2 positivo ahora cuanto es
menos por 2 x más bien pues esto me va a
quedar
por 2x pero 2 x completos menos 2
entonces menos por menos dos más que
pero llévale menos uno más menos uno muy
bien y por cierto cuántos esto esto es
menos menos dos menos uno es menos tres
y si ahora yo multiplico menos por menos
esto me da tres positivo muy bien
entonces aquí acabamos de ver luego
luego que le insisto a no es la
respuesta correcta porque acabamos de
encontrar un número que es más grande
que 2 que pasa con 2x bueno 2x de hecho
es un número negativo 2x es menos 2
entonces aquí me quedaría menos 2 y por
lo tanto esta tampoco es la respuesta
correcta de cero encuentro un número más
grande que cero por lo tanto tampoco es
la respuesta correcta y él me dice que
es menos y menos y es menos -1 y esto es
uno positivo pero 3 es más grande que
uno positivo y por lo tanto tampoco la
respuesta correcta y en este momento
podríamos concluir que la respuesta
correcta es
ve es mi respuesta correcta que es menos
2x más bien porque es número más grande
que encontramos en este caso particular
ahora seguramente te estás preguntando
que este caso particular está muy padre
pero funcionará para todos cualquier
número que te tomes menor que cero le
das el nombre de james y cualquier
número que te tomes menor que este
número james y le das el nombre de 2x
funciona para esto pues vamos a pensarlo
un poquito
aquí está la segunda forma de resolver
este mismo problema fíjate bien si que
es menor que cero y ya está entre dos
equis y cero entonces menos ya estaría
por aquí menor que sería este valor de
aquí menos y es positivo y menos lleva a
tener que estar entre cero y menos 2x
por acá va a estar menos 2x dicho de
otra manera si 2x es más negativo que
james entonces menos 2x va a ser más
positivo que menos yen y en este momento
es cuando tú podrías descartar esta
opción
y esta opción también y podrás descartar
también esta opción porque 2x es
negativo y entonces solamente te
quedaría pensar qué onda con estos dos
incisos es decir que es más grande menos
2x o menos 2x más yen pero para
responderte esta pregunta quiero que
veas lo siguiente si aquí te tomas un
número negativo y a esto le sumas un
número negativo entonces vas a llegar a
un número más negativo y cuando tú lo
conviertes a positivo con este signo de
menos vas a obtener un número mucho más
positivo dicho de otra manera
2x más que es mucho más negativo que 2x
porque le estamos sumando un número
negativo y entonces menos 2x más y es
más positivo si lo quieres ver de esta
manera que menos 2x porque le estamos
sumando un número positivo y entonces
podrías concluir que la respuesta
correcta es el inciso b que es justo lo
que queríamos espero que quede muy claro
este ejercicio podrías hacerlo de una
manera particular que creo que es la
forma mucho más sencilla y tal vez la
más clara tomarte algún valor
12 x tómate algún valor para james y
trabajar con estos sencillos que tenemos
aquí o la otra opción tal vez un poco
más abstracta sería pensar en estas
desigualdades que tenemos aquí y ver
quiénes más grandes y menos 2x o menos 2
x más bien pero bueno vamos a hacer el
siguiente problema y para esto voy a
borrar mi pantalla y voy a poner aquí el
problema número 13 y este problema dice
así dice que carlos el mensajero entrega
en paquetes el lunes entonces vamos a
apuntarlo el lunes el lunes entrega n
paquetes el lunes entrega n paquetes el
martes entrega 4 veces la cantidad de
paquetes que entregó el lunes el martes
el martes entrega 4 veces la cantidad de
paquetes que entregó el lunes es decir 4
veces en cuatro veces n es cuatro veces
la cantidad de paquetes que entregó el
lunes mientras que el miércoles y lo voy
a apuntar aquí de una vez
el miércoles que pasó miércoles lleva
acento entrega tres paquetes más de los
paquetes que entrega el lunes ojo
entrega tres paquetes más no quiere
decir que es el triple o tres veces la
cantidad sino que a la cantidad de
paquetes que entregó el lunes le vamos a
sumar tres y bueno lo que nos preguntan
es cuál es el promedio de paquetes que
se entregarán durante estos tres días es
decir yo lo que quiero saber es el
promedio de estos tres y bueno el
promedio es la suma de estos tres entre
la cantidad de días así que vamos a
sumarlos el promedio va a ser igual a n
más 4 n más n tres más n 3 ya esto hay
que dividirlo entre la cantidad de días
pero son tres días entonces entre 3 y
cuantos esto n4 n5 n más n son 6 n 6 n 3
ya esto lo voy a dividir entre 3
esto es igual puedo dividir esta parte
entre 3 y me queda 2n y después esta
parte entre 3 y me queda más 1 que por
cierto este es el inciso c el inciso c y
ya está aquí el problema número 3 cm así
que vamos el 14 todavía tenemos tiempo
el problema número 14 déjenme cambiar de
color para no hacerlo todo muy monótono
colores policromáticos dice si a más de
esto elevado a la potencia un medio guau
esto se ve interesante bastante bastante
prometedor esto es igual a a menos ve
esto elevado a la menos un medio
entonces cuáles las siguientes opciones
es correcta y aquí te voy a poner las
opciones con otro color el inciso am
dice que ve es igual a cero el inciso b
me dice que a más b
esto es igual a 1 el inciso se me dice
que a menos veces igual a 1
b esto es igual a 1 el inciso de me dice
que a cuadra damas b cuadrada a cuadrada
más b cuadrada
esto es lo que tiene que ser igual a 1
y por último el inciso me dice que a
cuadrado menos b cuadrada esto es lo que
tiene que ser igual a 1 cuál de estas es
la que tiene que ser igual a 1 y bueno
esta expresión que tengo aquí es mucho
más fácil manejarla de la siguiente
manera vamos a modificarlo un poco y la
voy a pensar de la siguiente forma esto
es lo mismo que decir la raíz cuadrada
de hamás b esto es igual a 1 entre la
raíz cuadrada de a menos b
recuerda que la potencia un medio es lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada y ahora voy a
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por la raíz cuadrada de a menos b a
menos ven y aquí por la raíz cuadrada de
a menos b a menos b y que me va a quedar
pues primero estos dos se van a cancelar
que eso va a ser bastante útil y me
queda esto igual a 1 y del lado
izquierdo me queda la raíz cuadrada de
quien pues de a menos b que multiplica a
su vez aa más b es decir estos dos
multiplicándose y ahora voy a elevar al
cuadrado a ambos lados de la ecuación
así que voy a llevar esta parte al
cuadrado y esta parte al cuadrado de tal
manera que la raíz cuadrada se va a
cancelar con este cuadrado y me queda
solamente a menos b que multiplica aa +
b y del otro lado me queda uno positivo
y ahora quiero que te fijes en esta
expresión que tengo aquí cuanto es a
menos b x
bueno pues esta es una diferencia de
cuadrados esto es exactamente lo mismo
que a cuadrado menos b cuadrada a
cuadrada el cuadrado del primero menos
el cuadrado del segundo esto es igual a
1 y qué creés esto es lo mismo que el
inciso y por lo tanto mi respuesta
correcta es el inciso y ya se me acabó
el tiempo así que veremos el siguiente
problema el cual parece bastante
entretenido en el siguiente vídeo nos
vemos pronto